[PIANO PLAYING]
LEONARD AUSTIN: Ravelin is
a fraud-detection company.
We specialize in detecting
credit card fraud.
When a customer tries
to buy something
from one of our
merchants, the merchant
will then stream us
all of that data,
and we will use a load
of machine learning
behind the scenes to try and
analyze transactions and make
predictions around whether
that user is a genuine user
or fraudulent user.
Security is really
important for us
because our clients are trusting
us with all of their data.
So we go to
extraordinary lengths
to ensure that the
data that we hold
is encrypted and secured
in closed-source projects.
So on-prem has the
problem of having
to manage your own security.
The actual cloud itself and
the way that Google structures
the file system
means that one file
isn't stored on one computer.
It's stored across
multiple disks, which
means even if someone
was able to get access
to a particular disk,
physical access,
they wouldn't actually be able
to get any data from that.
There's a number of
services that GCP offered
we couldn't get elsewhere,
like the Identity-Aware Proxy
and encryption at
rest by default,
but also the further step that
enables us to supply encryption
keys to Google, so that
Google can't even unencrypt
the data if they wanted to.
So those were all
really strong factors
that suggest that Google
really cares about security.
And it enables us to trust
Google with all of our data.